[Applause]
[Music]
happy monday my monday monsters what a
weekend huh i still haven't got all the
sand out of my butterfly net
so the dems passed a bill last night and
just like what joe passes after his
morning mush it's far from solid and it
stinks
and it should be flushed immediately
first of all never trust anything that
has more than one way to describe it you
know it's called the inflation reduction
act which is funny since no one knows
how it actually reduces inflation that's
like calling a hot fudge sundae the
brian stelter reduction act
even uh doc brown admits it's a ruse
before he climbed back into his delorean
i want to take a moment to say a few
words
about the so-called inflation reduction
act and i say so-called by the way
because according to the cbo
and other economic organizations who
have studied this bill
it will in fact have a minimal
impact on inflation yeah which is tough
for bernie he's going to have to wait on
that shower chair he had his eye on
yeah he's come in and just put it right
over the bathtub
but that's why this bill comes with so
many names it's the same way
professional con artists have many
aliases it's designed to confuse you and
hide the grift some call it the
inflation act or the health care act
then of course it's the climate act why
not call it the sex act since we're all
getting screwed
that's why i sit here huh
it's the kama sutra for greedy
bureaucrats
but the worst is this new irs army of 85
87 000 agents to find tax cheats the
thing is in order to find them you have
to cast a much wider net people who work
hard and make a lot of money are going
to be like dolphins who accidentally get
caught in fishermen's nets that were
meant for sardines and salmon
the washington post calls it modernizing
the tax collector which is a gentle way
of saying arming the government to go
after more taxpayers to pay off their
orgy of spending it's a feedback loop
spend more money create more agents to
get it rinse and repeat till the end of
time so you got a choice when you're
audited you hire an accountant or a
lawyer to help defend your case or you
just avoid the hassle and you pay up and
that's what they hope you do every time
it's stop and frisk for years on end for
grandmas but at least it's inclusive
you should be thanking them for their
audit and at least for using lube this
time
yeah
lube
the media calls it necessary something
they'd never say about the real police
right they'd prefer to refund and arm
the cops who go after you rather than
violent criminals which makes sense
since they already believe half of us
are domestic terrorists
and also you know white-collar criminals
they don't shoot back when they're
arrested
the proponents claim that it will cover
higher earners but when they run out of
those as they always do they just keep
lowering the bar to include everyone
else you know the irs are like guys who
head out to a bar on saturday night with
the intentions of picking up a 10.
but by the time last call rolls around
they're staring at a three and thinking
she's got most of her teeth
and one good eye that's close enough
it's called the jim norton rule
fact is you don't need 87 000 agents to
go after the very few rich there's only
538 people in congress
and don't buy the lie
yeah
and don't buy that this these agency
improvements are here to help
four percent of the 80 billion is going
to taxpayer services while 57 goes to
enforcement that's as level as a gulf
stream carrying chris christie
it's a small plane
[Laughter]
so what happens well you when you crack
down on the rich the returns diminish
because they hire accountants and
lawyers to fight it it becomes a long
war of agents and lawyers as resources
disappear on both sides
so why do it well it's to appear fair
right remember in politics perception
and deception is everything it's
important to soak the rich even if they
aren't rich or already soaked by
inflation and it's on you for being
scared roll it clarence
can you understand how 87 000 new irs
agents would scare the heck out of
millions of americans there's no reason
to be fearful and if you have paid your
taxes and if you comply with our laws
you should want to make sure everyone
else does that yeah remember show me the
man and i'll show you the crime now it's
show me the w-4 and i'll show you the
fine
but it's not like our government ever
targets the people it hates right
and yeah if you're ever charged with a
crime and you're innocent why should you
worry right it's not like people ever
get wrongly convicted
oh my god yeah
thank you thank you
yeah send your letters to me
so how does this help you well first
there's crime inflation your kids are in
crappy schools gas prices are eating
into your beer budget
luckily the government's working to make
sure you have nothing so then you have
nothing to hide here's irs agent adam
markowitz justifying this new army he
says quote all of my gop friends who are
worried about these new irs agents
coming after the little guy how about
just don't cheat on tax returns a fully
truthful and accurate tax return is
bulletproof i never understood the fear
of an irs audit
well i like how it's just his imaginary
gop friends
who fear this new irs army
and he never understood the fear well
it's always tantamount of charging you
with a crime and it's up to you to clear
yourself of the charge that's what
people fear you schmuck bottom line a
person can actually go to jail if they
just aren't that organized
like cat
but then this agent admits in a later
tweet i get that it's a headache to go
through an audit
[Laughter]
all right
so you when you get finished being
audited by the irs it's not your head
that's aching pal you're at the wrong
end of the horse
and he's an ass comparing the irs to the
feeling i get from ice cream
then he adds and i get that it's costly
to go through an audit and nobody ever
wins well wait a second jackass you just
said no one should fear an audit then
you say exactly why they should fear it
it disrupts your life and nobody ever
wins i got a question for you what are
the property taxes in fantasy island
where you live
but
but if you have an iq higher than an
artichoke you must see that by now this
country's heading towards a police state
where the police state
they want your money now and if you
don't do see that now do me a favor and
change the channel i think fallon is
playing beer pong with harry connick jr
right now
let's welcome tonight's guest
her broadcasting skills give her
audience the chills host of the sideline
sanity podcast michelle tafoya
[Applause]
his magazine inspired a movement it's
why i keep it in the bathroom
reason editor at large nick gillespie
[Applause]
he likes his women like he likes his
coffee
doesn't always have to be coffee
comedian and co-host of the jim norton
and sam robert's show
jim norton on siriusxm
and she's so light she can't fly a kite
unsupervised boxes
jim as one american treasure to another
american treasure it's so good to see
you and it's a delight to see you greg
thank you so much yes i always feel so
special when you're in my presence i i
feel the same way and i think i speak
for the entire audience when i say your
ankles are driving me crazy
yeah thank you
you know i decided not to wear socks
today i like it yeah i like to let the
bites breathe
[Laughter]
anyway are you frightened of the irs i
think you should i mean how do you pay
for those massage visits
well if they what were the other options
if that's what they settled on like do
we get 87 000 more agents or condoms
filled with itching powder or monkey
i like the irs i mean they give her to a
party and it sucks what's wrong with
this party no irs guys they're great
i'm still laughing about condoms filled
with itching
like i wear them
[Laughter]
so how you doing there michelle you're
good how are you i i dig the i dig the
leather oh thanks yeah yeah you look
like trouble
what do you think about this bill what
you know why they the thing that gets me
angry is that how they just complicate
things when they could just do a table
of contents tell us what's in it
they never do they never do and they're
celebrating all this spending by the way
dems are celebrating the spending why
are we celebrating spending i mean i
thought when we had this american rescue
act we were supposed to all be better
off and in fact were worse off um but
here's the thing if this does in fact
very doubtful reduce inflation then
schumer and his gang are going to take a
victory lap as i see what we did even if
it has nothing to do with this bill
right
if inflation goes up and taxes go up as
they invariably will schumer and company
will point to something else right and
that's the beauty of having legislation
that has so much crap built in you don't
know what's there you don't know what to
point to did you know the tax code is
over a million words that's equivalent
to the entire harry potter harry potter
harry potter series
i meant to say harry potter harry potter
i prefer a harry potter i gave him an
idea
my point
my point being that it would take
forever to read this thing right no
one's going to we want to rely on other
people to decipher exactly and we don't
know who to trust no it's true i think
the bit they they they design this thing
so big that even i don't even think the
senators and nobody reads no nobody
reads it nick you were you know you've
been nice fringe by the way thank you
yeah it's like a harry potter philosophy
so how long have you had that jacket uh
you know i woke up and it was on me this
morning
[Laughter]
i can't say 12 14 hours oh you spent the
night with kudlow huh you know what's
great is he'll treat you like but then
you get a free jacket
sometimes you know that's just like
liberace
anyway um nick uh you're no matter what
you're always gonna be disappointed in
this process because you're a
libertarian the show or the government
the uh the bill it's against spending
you will always be on the losing side
because you're libertarian true so how
do you uh in the long run we went okay
because we're dead and you showed jesus
before yes
i'm really looking forward to jesus was
the first libertarian that's right yeah
he he didn't really play with uh the
government no he did he did the
government that's right
and he you know we hung out with all
businessman
on psychedelics mostly exactly exactly i
mean how else was he walking on water
he wasn't walking on water he thought
[Laughter]
um what's the worst part of this the
bill uh
you know well
right from the get-go the idea that this
is going to reduce inflation by spending
massive amounts of money because
one of the reasons we have inflation is
because the government has jacked up
spending so much so fast over a short
period of time plus a long period of
time plus the fed and you know people
are saying okay this is about reducing
inflation but what's really good about
it is it's going to save the environment
where it's going to help the you know
it's going to help the irs finally get
back up to fighting strength after
they were starving you know during the
2018 they were underfunded yeah you know
that yeah i had no idea
it is you you mentioned this but uh you
know the irs within recent memory has a
history of targeting of making
politically motivated audits right of
nonprofits and things like that the
other thing i'll say about all the irs
stuff
there are five times as many audits of
people making under 25 grand as there
are on average because most audits are
correspondence audits so it's like you
get a phone call or you get letters and
it's poor people or low-income people
who are getting the earned income tax
credit which is a policy to help the
working poor they get most of the
contact with the irs that's amazing why
am i worried about it yeah
well i'm joking that's disgusting yeah
that's crazy the you know the laws never
fall equally on the rich and the poor
yeah well thank god for that right cat
by the way uh same plans on the yacht
later right
uh you're in the green room you said you
were you're happy there's a they've
doubled the size of the irs army i was
surprised
no i would never say that i think it's
awful and i hate all the people who are
saying
you know if you're not doing anything
wrong you shouldn't worry about it
everyone knows that's not true because
what's the scariest thing anyone can
ever say to you we need to talk right
that's the scariest thing and it's a lot
worse when it's coming from the irs
because they can send you to prison
because you know like as you said you're
disorganized which is why again i'm so
glad that i got married because
like
he handles all my administrative stuff
now so
so if i ever got audited you know what i
would do
babe
that's it
when you look at it that way
when you look at it that way it's like
when somebody says we need to talk
you are not aware of what you did wrong
yeah you're never aware of what you did
wrong and that's the same thing with an
audit yeah and it's also like if you get
sued or deposed or anything like that
it's the same thing you never know greg
i'm always aware of what i did wrong
and this whole don't cheat on your taxes
thing i hate to break it to the
government but i cheat on my girlfriend
i'm cheating on you too
i hope they don't watch
for your sake and for mine hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else